yeah tell you the time I got in a street
fight with a bunch of [ __ ] dudes in
Hoboken New Jersey
I don't think so now I'm walking with my
girl Kelly and shout out to Kelly Kelly
and housekey Kapowski nope nope
but she's Slater nope nope no Kelly
Slater the surfer who I was back when
she was a girl and I'm in Hoboken New
Jersey walking after dinner and three
young ruffians let's call him
they were probably I was 23 and they
were 18 maybe even 17 maybe 14 nope nope
but they weren't they were older I'll
tell you why I know that so the guy goes
the guy goes now [ __ ] your girl and I
think I go mmm
can't have that wait we guys just
walking by yeah in this way mouths [ __ ]
yo girl I stop and I turn ha no dude
[ __ ] your girl for me again let me
forget that
let's go [ __ ] your girl that's tough one
more time nah [ __ ] you go mmm
they were not black Italian they were
probably Hispanic probably Puerto Rican
as they would say on the street swaps
yeah no that's that Rachel turn wapis
you know what that stands for
that's what you call an Italian and that
was that was it was a derogatory term
because it mean it meant without papers
so if you came from Italy or a wall yeah
like my family my immigrant family they
didn't have papers almost calling Lexi
and aliens yeah but it was kind of worse
back then gone Italians so they dared I
heard it in a what's the movie where a
young kid of Bronx yeah a Brock
Scottsdale yeah they call this if you
said that to my grandfather who was
Sicilian he'd lose his [ __ ] mind out
on you knows it was very very so driving
so these kids were wops or no they were
not they were they were of Puerto Rican
descent okay
what's a derogatory term for a Puerto
Rican I mean but Mary you know they I
don't know Rican I don't know what they
Ricans awesome yeah yeah I mean the
Puerto Ricans have a lot of pride and in
New York there's a there's a lot of like
a lot of them were to reconvene and then
the manufacturing jobs laugh
for the south so there was a huge Porto
Rican population that didn't have the
ability to work so then you had you know
kids that were living in projects and
then you know trouble ensued and stuff
but but there's a lot of pride like a
lot of Puerto Ricans you very prideful
like hot girl port around I'm on the
favorites some of my famous a my fav
back the story of those seminars
beautiful Ricans were a chirping I think
they might have imported reading them
but you know but then again you know
there could be a mix of things but
anyway so by the way they're kids and
and I come back I turn around and I go
what did you say about my girl and he
goes I won't say anybody girl man he's
looking down he goes yes I go alright
and I walk in he goes but I'll [ __ ] your
girl now I turn back around and I go
you're talking to me now
and he goes whatever shoes move on move
on shoes on shoes I had a pair of black
shoes and back then I would always wear
black shoes and I preferred with the
steel-toed boot steel toe and soles I
could get to the traction on they know
the route also I could kick I was
Taekwondo guy remember okay
wrestler cyclone over I know you laugh
but this is my street friends you go
much well dude I'm not big see what
happens is I'm cute dog you understand
I'm a hothead because let he told you
shoes they thought these black boots
yeah they were shoes they weren't even
boots of armor their shoes so anyway I
think they were like they were like Doc
Martens but not Doc Martens because I
didn't like Doc Martens cuz skinhead
words time blah blah so anyway so uh he
calls me shoes and then I kicked him
like a tease him I tried to kick him in
the face throw hot head man I kind of
miss shoes babes hi yeah well there no
no cuz you're saying I'm gonna [ __ ] your
girl I know but that's a I'm tried to
move on shoes and then and then I I
kicked I knew he was [ __ ] with me cuz
he was talking my girl and I kicked him
the face I didn't quite hit him in the
face I think I hit him in the shoulder
long story short he jumps on me and
grabs
around the waist and now I'm punching
him look in the head can't hurt him yeah
I can't hurt him nolan ryan stuff yeah
but I'm not hurting him I'm hitting him
and I'm and and then his two buddies are
circling me but they're not hitting in
weird one kid tries to hit me I kind of
duck it's very awkward nobody's tough
here okay I think a [ __ ] fest it's a
[ __ ] fest to Sesame Street
now a woman a girl who's one of their
friends come over to us I remember to
never forget her she goes how old are
you how old do you sir as I'm beating
these kids up okay but they're 18 so
[ __ ] I don't think they when I'm trying
to Kathleen word there were 13 you were
20 kids they were up they were both my
size two kids we're talking definitely
not suppose to the puerto rican long
story short now you know i'm trying to
punch this guy I'm kidding I can't hurt
him you know the kids off I can't hurt
him
a cop comes running up I get away from
the kid I get away from the kid throw
another kick and I wasn't all that was
23 I didn't say secure I didn't got sick
I take that matter regions I do what is
this I think I can't do it that wasn't
all that was a young tight skin you have
prior two weeks ago sir about three
weeks here now listen so long story
short nobody gets hurt the cop comes
running up goes who's fighting well I
know but when the cop came running up I
moved and I bounced off him and he goes
who's fighting and I go those guys
grabbed my girl ran away now here's
what's great about the story here's what
the hell [ __ ] up I am I'm so angry
went back and got again that old bride
goes gets in his car
I had an Acura white Acura all bride
gets in his car and I get a [ __ ]
stick
I had an axe handle I had an axe handle
I Hickory axe handle cuz I saw it in a
movie somewhere somebody shell talk
about hair cream and now I'm driving
around looking for these [ __ ] guys
because I'm gonna I'm gonna hit him as
hard as I can and in the head that's how
crazy I was never ran into all the Liam
Neeson story when he was searching for
black know your surgeon for no that's
not
true never found him for a week a week
that's how I growl moms huh I had wrong
you problems I pried stuff you know he
sell problems I get I get so I agree
injustice guy felt like they were being
rapists or something I had they I don't
really just gradually talking on my foot
no no they were doing it they were doing
it to me at my girl
it wasn't ia was rapey it was rapey you
know me I love everybody you know me if
I'm your honor but if I'm mad at - yeah
but I'm also doing the Lord's work in
that situation
Donaire cakes isn't the Lord's work i
grazed him was like wow but you have to
not go seek gay I'm gonna leave now
because this is embarrassing it was yeah
I didn't really a shoe it wasn't that
impressive no I felt can I be honest I
remember this the other thing I felt
weak then I will just didn't feel strong
I couldn't get him off me and if those
other guys tried it I just it was a
couple 14 euros no no no they were 18
you got it they were poor we goofed up
tell eh - well yeah they had full beards
but no pubes um cuz they were naked oh
yeah
well at least no one got hurt dude
that's my street fights I've never been
that guy man I don't have that angery I
dated a girl one time don't get yeah you
have that no but here's what you have
with business I know here's what you
have not with people you and I have this
other thing that we have and I think we
have this in common when I saw a movie
one time Brian Dennehy plays an evil guy
and the guy was talking about him cuz he
doesn't and he goes well problem with
him is he gets a notion about you when
he gets an ocean tends to grow and take
on a life of its own
do you understand until it swirls no
like a little seed weirdo saying like I
got an ocean I got a thing you know I
think that guy's [ __ ] me yeah but I'm
always off though like course we were
always off but doesn't mean you can
sleep all night no I'll get that but
then like if I don't like so and then
let's say run into him wherever it is
not that I don't like any comic let's
say the economy store I've run into them
I'm fine I'm course you are I'm Mike
what's up dude you don't care whatever
at 9:00 it's just when you're sleeping
yeah when you get a little thing and
you're like but I never have that liking
them I never anger issue or anything
like no you don't have an anger so
they'd never fight anyone over anything
no well you first I lose lose who you
gonna fight yeah but just say even but
even when I was younger I'd never yeah
never my thing yeah you're not well but
I mean you were always bigger and
stronger right no nausea we but go over
the side was a late bloomer man yeah my
brother was the big strong one yeah I
never had any of that but I think I feel
like you were just an athlete and you
never had to prove that for other guys
it's like for me I just got bullied when
I was in eighth grade got a little scar
yeah I was bullied for a whole year so
when that happens to you I talked to the
therapist about it but he goes because
cuz I I was talking about being I was
talking about being a ha like I got a
lot about no I got hot in couples
therapy okay and he said you're
comfortable in this warrior energy they
talk this way I go I don't know about
that he goes were you bullied and I went
for a whole year in eighth grade a year
a whole year in seventh grade actually
long time ago though you know you don't
get over he said that's when no he said
that's India that's a program thing
because because if now it's like if
you're pulling me out kill you will you
be able to defend you yeah you'll be
able to do something I get I get that
but there's a lot of people like that
like - ever talks on his podcast all
time how he still feels like the loser
kid when he's 12 years old and detorri
Michigan yep because he was really tall
and skinny didn't get any girls so he
for whatever reason that got calculate
you know ingrained in his brain right at
that time when he's 12
mm-hmm I really have things I think the
reason I have a chip on my sure I have
things that happened in sports where I
was treated different than other people
yeah that in grains were you know you're
always trying to prove something it's a
gift